[Music]
mark zuckerberg was a harvard freshman
with a gift for computer programming
less than a decade later he is the
baby-faced multi-billionaire power
broker who rubs shoulders with the
president my name is barack obama and
i'm the guy who got mark to wear a
jacket and tie i think most people still
haven't really digested the scale of
facebook or how quickly it's grown the
goal is obviously to get to ubiquity i
mean mark zuckerberg wants everyone to
be on this service he transformed the
dorm room project into the internet's
biggest global village
the site now has over 900 million users
can't underestimate how driven mark
zuckerberg really is zuckerberg is just
as visionary as steve jobs
he's going to prove just as influential
as bill gates
but for all that success zuckerberg has
confronted bitter battles and lawsuits
over facebook's origins one he wanted to
control his own thing and two if he's
gonna go against someone he's gonna
crush them
we spent three months working with mark
being essentially led on we were all
blindsided we had no idea that you know
he was working on a competing product he
has waged an all-out war on his biggest
competitors facebook and google's
relationship is pretty simple they just
don't like each other and zuckerberg has
come under fire for pushing the limits
on user privacy users have less control
over private information they don't
fully know how their information is
being shared he's not dealing with just
a piece of technology
he's dealing with people
and their behavior and in many ways he's
doing it on the fly
they have amassed this humongous
database of information about us because
we trusted them
so the question is should we still trust
them
[Music]
i think that the goal that we went into
it with
wasn't to make an online community but
sort of like a mirror for the real
community that existed in real life
mark zuckerberg we think we know him
because we've seen his life unfold in
the oscar-winning movie the social
network the portrait was unsparing a
super geek intense cutthroat brilliant
and socially crippled i don't understand
which part but was it accurate he's
always had friends you know he's a
pretty social guy
um i think the last time i checked
879 friends on facebook
this is the real mark zuckerberg in
rarely seen footage shot at facebook's
first corporate headquarters by young
filmmakers in 2005.
what are we celebrating it's got 3
million users 3 million users yeah and
how long has facebook been around
not that long
a little more than a year
while zuckerberg pushes the envelope on
user privacy he opted out of
participating in this program
in 2004 at the age of 19 he created
facebook today the 28 year old ceo has
accumulated a net worth estimated at
15.5 billion dollars mark's mission from
the beginning was about connecting
people and it was clearly based on this
theory that if the world were more
connected it would be a better place but
there's a lot of surprises when you
really dig deep into the story of
facebook the biggest single surprise is
the peculiar and uh tenacious
personality of mark zuckerberg and you
the the depth of his convictions and his
consistency
[Music]
born in 1984 he grew up in the hudson
river town of dobbs ferry a bedroom
community north of new york city
david kirkpatrick spent two years
researching a book about zuckerberg and
facebook called the facebook effect he
comes from an unbelievably supportive
family in which he's the only son and he
has three sisters so he was kind of the
prince and in fact i think his parents
called him the prince and he was treated
accordingly so this is a guy without any
problem of self-confidence computer
savvy from the start zuckerberg taught
himself the complicated computer
language c plus and by ninth grade had
created a digital version of the board
game risk journalist jose antonio vargas
interviewed zuckerberg for his new
yorker magazine profile he actually
created a thing called zucknet
which is an internal instant messaging
system for the family so the computers
could talk to each other
and that's kind of the kid he was
[Music]
when he got sort of tired of his local
high school he decided to go to exeter
prep school really because he just
wanted more challenge it was at the
exclusive exeter academy that zuckerberg
and his friend adam deangelo created a
music website called synapse it was
intended to anticipate what your
preferences might be
and it was very very popular even before
he started facebook he was fending off
offers from microsoft and others to buy
synapse for well over a million dollars
like a tech world version of an all-star
athlete big name companies wanted to
recruit him right out of exeter
again zuckerberg was unimpressed and
chose instead to enter harvard in
2002 where it wasn't long before he got
himself in trouble
zuckerberg hacked into the school's
computers to collect images of students
nicholas carlson is deputy editor at
businessinsider.com
you can sort of tell that he's a little
bit of a troublemaker he creates
something called face mash his first
year in harvard and it's a sort of hot
or not for the harvard community and
then it maintained an entire list of
harvard students and which ones were the
most attractive ranking them by hotness
ellen mcgirt interviewed zuckerberg for
fast company magazine
face mash worked in kind of a a little
bit of an icky way it made people upset
obviously people felt mocked or exposed
and it was one of the first big
experiences that mark had with the
privacy issues of the masses
under pressure zuckerberg shut down the
site the harvard administration board
charged him with breaching security
violating copyrights and violating
individual privacy
but by then facemash was a campus
sensation zuckerberg had seen his future
at the same time getting trouble for the
building this mischievous web tool he
built a mischievous web tool that was
really popular i imagine that he had a
couple of sleepless nights worrying
about how how bad this thing was going
to be it was relieved when it all blew
over
but was also incredibly curious about
what he could then make next
if you're a genius with genius friends
sitting in a dorm room suddenly the
world looks like a big happy open place
if you can just get into that database
at the time the technology landscape was
changing dramatically
brad stone is a senior writer at
bloomberg businessweek the internet was
was really a much different world back
in 2004 friendster really demonstrates
that a social network needs to have
technical chops the site goes down all
the time it's unreliable myspace also
it's full of ads it's very distracting
it also begins to have technical
instability
at harvard zuckerberg met classmate and
future business partner eduardo saverin
author ben mesrick is one of the few to
have interviewed saverin about the early
days of facebook eduardo met mark
zuckerberg in an underground jewish
fraternity the underground scene at
harvard you know these were not really
fun events these were kind of strange
little social settings really bad
parties mostly all guys and so eduardo
and mark met in this scene um and they
became friends pretty quickly because
they were both kind of outsiders
facemash got zuckerberg noticed by three
insiders upperclassmen building a social
networking site called harvard
connection olympic rowers and twins
cameron and tyler winklevoss with
partner divia narendra
harvard connection was an idea that i'd
come up with when i was a junior in
college since at the end of 2002. the
team had been building the site for
nearly a year two of their original
programmers had moved on and they
desperately needed a new partner the
three of us are not computer programmers
by by trade or practice we did need an
actual programmer to write the actual
hard lines of code and we thought mark
was that guy
the trio reached out to zuckerberg
he was enthused excited
and clearly his his eyes were lighting
up
what happened next sparked a furious
battle over how facebook was actually
created
the details unfold in email exchanges
between zuckerberg and the harvard
connection team
at first zuckerberg appeared eager
i read over all the stuff you sent and
it seems like it shouldn't take too long
to implement so we can talk about that
after i get all the basic functionality
up tomorrow night then zuckerberg began
to delay the project
december 4th sorry i was unreachable
tonight i just got about three of your
missed calls i was working on a problem
set
december 10th the week has been pretty
busy thus far so i haven't gotten a
chance to do much work on the site or
even think about it really
zuckerberg was stalling because he was
busy working on a similar social
networking site based on harvard's
student directory called the facebook
he and severin partnered to fund it mark
came to him and said you know you put up
a thousand dollars and we'll launch this
site and you know there were no
contracts these were just two kids in a
dorm room really um but that's where it
started writer nicholas carlson
interviewed more than a dozen people
involved in the founding of facebook and
found instant messages retrieved from
zuckerberg's computer he said zuckerberg
sent to saverin according to business
insider the i am suggests zuckerberg was
deliberately misleading the winklevoss
twins he says things like look at this
site that i'm working on harvard
connection haha they made a mistake they
asked me to do it for them because i'm
working on my own facebook we were
always under the impression that mark
was working on harvardconnection.com
there was never an indication from him
that he could not do the work uh didn't
want to do the work or was working on
something identical on the side called
uh the facebook when he met with the
winklevoss brothers the last time he saw
that he probably should tell them that
he's been working on a competing product
he sort of conferred about it with
friends but in the end he said you know
what i'm gonna do i'm gonna blank them
i'm gonna blank them in the ear
on february 4th 2004 just as he was
expected to complete work on their site
zuckerberg and his friends instead
launched the facebook the winklevoss
brothers and narendra found out about it
the same way nearly everyone else at
harvard did it completely blindsided us
we
definitely did not expect that
mark wanted to have control over his own
project he saw that they were on to
something cool the winklevoss brothers
but he saw that he could do something
cooler and so
one he wanted to control his own thing
and two if he's going to go against
someone he's going to crush them and
that's what he did mark zuckerberg's new
harvard-based social networking site the
facebook was mired in controversy from
the start just days after he launched it
in february of 2004 the winklevoss twins
and divia narendra sent him a letter to
cease and desist
in a nutshell our complaint against mark
zuckerberg is fraud unjust enrichment
and breach of contract
zuckerberg responded with a letter
denying any wrongdoing claiming his site
was a separate venture and used none of
the same code
the winklevoss twins and narendra would
later appeal a 65 million dollar
settlement with facebook they lost in
federal court but that settlement could
now be worth 200 million dollars but
none of the vicious legal wrangling
slowed the incredible momentum of the
facebook
at that point my roommates were kind of
like you know this is pretty cool like i
bet this would work at other schools so
we launched it at columbia yale and
stanford and within a couple of weeks
each of those three schools
also like had thousands of users who
were like all right this is pretty sweet
like let's just go all out and see how
many schools we can launch the site as
quickly as possible about this point in
time um they started to take meetings
with venture capitalists and with bigger
advertisers and this is all kind of
eduardo's doing they got a pretty early
deal with uh visa
and they had a deal with american
express
they had a number of advertisers that
came and went
then record companies started getting
interested and they began to get some
pretty good revenue from the music
industry
enter sean parker who had his own
connection to the music business
on a trip to new york zuckerberg and his
partner eduardo saverin had dinner with
the 24 year old co-founder of napster
the seasoned entrepreneur and a truly
creative individual an extraordinarily
interesting person who had worked his
way into a network in the valley that is
just to die for it particularly at that
point
for zuckerberg parker was a hero and a
role model partner saverin didn't agree
eduardo did not think highly of sean
from the very beginning uh he thought
that sean was a snake oil salesman that
they didn't need sean
that sean talked to big game but was
living out of a duffel bag and had been
kicked out of two companies
in the summer of 2004 with saverin
remaining on the east coast zuckerberg
left harvard we came out to palo alto
for this summer just to hang out because
palo alto is kind of this mythical place
where you know all the startups come
from and
got ready to launch at another 150
schools when the year started one of the
things that mark did that was very smart
by going to palo alto was to actually
enter the petri dish of
entrepreneurialism particularly for new
technologies
zuckerberg and his friends moved into a
large frame house with a swimming pool
and he reconnected with sean parker who
later became zuckerberg's roommate he
was the adult supervision he's the guy
who showed them how things are done in
silicon valley he's the one who showed
them how to meet investors
how to negotiate with them
who to hire mark has told me stories of
just all of the guys
coding late at night around dining room
tables and eating chicken mcnuggets and
cereal and
there's partying going on sean parker is
bringing them around to the different
kind of cool silicon valley hot spots
and meanwhile the website is is growing
astronomically fast i mean there's a
million member party by december of that
year
during this time parker gave zuckerberg
some shrewd advice he took to heart he
sort of looked at him and said you need
to be the founder of this thing and you
need to be the ceo forever you know you
can't turn this over to investors and
mark is able to negotiate a series of
increasingly important investment deals
that do two things one allow him enough
operating cash to hire some of the
smartest engineers in the business and
to help him retain majority control in
the company
but tensions began to grow with
zuckerberg's original partner eduardo
saverin who remained on the east coast
eduardo felt that you know he was the
business head of the company and he was
no longer being treated that way
you know mark and sean were taking
meetings all over california they were
meeting with venture capitalists and
they were kind of ignoring eduardo he
retaliated eduardo froze the bank
accounts to try and get mark's attention
and mark and sean began to sort of
figure out a way
to build the company without eduardo
zuckerberg responded and froze saverin
out
eduardo was removed from the company
masthead and he essentially became a
non-entity he became a non-person um he
was thrown out and he became very upset
facebook had a million active users on
college campuses nationwide and big
money was starting to pour in
sean parker the new president of
facebook introduced zuckerberg to
silicon valley angel investor peter
thiel who put five hundred thousand
dollars into the company then in the
spring of 2005 the venture capital firm
excel partners offered zuckerberg 12.7
million dollars for an 11 stake in the
company and didn't ask for much control
at all walking away from that investment
mark controlled three out of five board
seats which is
a bizarre and unprecedented situation to
have one individual
have absolute effectively dictatorial
control over the disposition and
direction of an increasingly giant
company overnight the excel investment
gave facebook a valuation of 100 million
dollars as facebook's public profile
grew so did zuckerberg's control this
time sean parker was edged out in august
of 2005 parker was arrested for
suspicion of cocaine possession although
not formally charged with a crime and
immediately released it led to his
abrupt resignation as president of
facebook he was the primary outside face
of the company and it was felt that
somebody who was under any kind of a
cloud with drugs
was not the right guy to be the public
face of facebook so mark reluctantly
agreed that he ought to leave facebook
was growing with remarkable speed and
zuckerberg moved the company from its
frat-like house with the pool to a
larger and more conventional space in
downtown palo alto
but the college atmosphere remained the
same
one of the things that
i do focus on at facebook is
making sure that the culture is very
friendly you know and that people hang
out in terms of managing
this whole process
nothing you know nothing like i have no
idea what i'm doing you know
even their employee interviews were
different
chris kelly was brought on in the new
position of chief privacy officer to
deal with facebook's increasingly
contentious privacy issues at a time
when the entire company numbered only a
couple dozen employees the first time i
met mark we we climbed out on the roof
out through the uh the window
and did our interview on the roof of of
what was then a world wraps and it was
clear he was young but
um he had a very sophisticated
understanding of what had happened so
far
and where he wanted to take the company
determined to keep facebook's unusual
creative culture alive
all night hackathons were one way to do
it we have these hackathons at the
company right where basically everyone
gets together
and just hacks on something and build
something
um all night long and the only the only
rule is that
you aren't allowed to work on at a
hackathon what you work on the rest of
the time so people work on crazy stuff
the hackathons were some of the most
kind of creative focus that you could
ever imagine in a company imagining
these
incredibly talented engineers coming
together for a night
and saying we're going to stay up all
night and we're just going to program
and we're going to we're going to pick a
project
and we're gonna get it done that night
it's like great make it we'll prototype
it and there'll be a prototype war and
see who wins it can be a contentious
environment oh man they wouldn't be able
to get all the way across no i disagree
that's [ __ ] we had an argument from
mark's point of view this is where good
ideas come from quickly and efficiently
good ideas were flowing zuckerberg then
made a change that would give facebook a
sudden and dramatic boost allowing
people to identify or tag themselves and
their friends in photographs that was
a huge huge change that led to massive
new use of facebook and photos became
very rapidly by far the most used part
of facebook and became the single
biggest driver of its growth
that growth continued in one direction
up
according to facebook's internal
tracking its user base had shot to 5.5
million users in less than two years
and media giants were banging on the
door
in 2006 yahoo baited the 22 year old
zuckerberg with an extraordinary offer a
buyout for one billion dollars
even more extraordinary zuckerberg
turned them down
now if you are a parent of someone about
mark's age
you're looking at the yahoo decision and
thinking
why did you not take that money
it's never been about money if it was it
would have just sold out we just felt
that doing that and going down that path
would not help us build facebook out to
what we thought it could be in 2006 mark
zuckerberg rejected a one billion dollar
pitch from yahoo when mtv pushed the
ante even higher michael j wolf was ceo
of mtv networks mark had taken me on a
walk around palo alto and showed me
his apartment
and afterwards we sat down for a lunch
and i told him we'd be willing to pay as
much as a billion and a half dollars to
buy facebook outright his answer was
i think it's worth a lot more
and besides you've seen my apartment i
don't really need that kind of money and
at the same time
i may never have an idea as good as this
one so i'm not that interested in
selling there was internal strife around
it no question there were a lot of
people who wanted to sell ultimately you
know mark decided to turn down the
offers
zuckerberg wasn't ready to sell because
he had some ideas that he thought would
make facebook even more popular one of
them was called news feed a kind of
real-time wire service of updates about
what users were up to news feed is what
everybody is doing at that point or what
they're posting what they're linking to
the world that they live in which is
really what a newspaper is right it's a
living breathing newspaper of people
around you but many facebook users
thought that newspaper sent out too much
information and violated their privacy
seven hundred and fifty thousand of them
launched an online protest
to say that it was unpopular at first is
a dramatic understatement they were
under siege at the office they couldn't
leave they were surrounded by news
trucks almost 10 percent of our user
base at the time
joined the students against facebook
news feed group
zuckerberg was forced to apologize
he wrote his apology note himself it was
probably a good learning experience when
facebook changed some of the privacy
controls it was an overstep i do think
he takes those seriously
but i do think that he's willing to
continue to overstep
for the for the purpose of making a
product that he wants to make the
apology was not a surrender zuckerberg
was sure that users would get used to
this new level of sharing and he turned
out to be right after tweaking news feed
it became one of the most popular
elements of the facebook experience
it just happened that the first time i
ever met mark was two days after that
happened
and i can tell you even though his
members were an open revolt he was not
the slightest bit flustered he had
complete confidence
that everything was going to work out
all right
zuckerberg decided it was time to take
facebook beyond its college roots and
introduce it to the general public the
response was stunning membership doubled
shooting up to 12 million by 2006.
zuckerberg radically altered the
facebook experience again when for the
first time the 23 year old ceo invited
programmers from around the world to
develop apps for facebook
it was another turning point expanding
facebook from an insular world of
information to a platform and it was
like the gold rush
you open up this wonderful platform and
in comes every kind of developer with
every kind of idea from video sharing to
games to things that blink to things
that turned into you know ballerinas and
hippos and just every kind of fun
wonderful thing
the platform companies or the operating
system companies always do the best i
mean think of microsoft you know it had
this ubiquitous windows platform and all
these other
companies wrote programs for windows you
know facebook's really trying to create
itself in that model
and in 2007 microsoft itself entered the
picture this time with a deal zuckerberg
couldn't turn down and for the first
time the world got a glimpse of what
facebook may really be worth by the time
people were finally getting used to the
idea that anyone would pay a billion
dollars for facebook microsoft comes
along and pays
250 million dollars for 1.6
of the company it was outrageous it
valued the company at 15 billion
this took facebook from a thing that a
lot of people use to a thing that
everyone was talking about the 15
billion dollar company
but for a 15 billion dollar company
facebook was only making a meager 30
million dollars in profits to remedy
that zuckerberg announced a sweeping new
advertising system in the fall of 2007
one part of it let companies set up
their own facebook pages and advertise
using social ads lou kerner covers
social media and owns shares in facebook
social ads on facebook are ads where
they would say that your friends meg and
ryan like virgin america and it turns
out not surprisingly that when you see
that your friends like a product you're
more likely to click on that ad so
social ads have been very successful on
facebook virtually from the beginning
but another part of facebook's new
advertising plan beacon gave users far
more than they wanted and they let
zuckerberg know about it
zuckerberg's made a lot of mistakes the
next mistake which was a really big one
was beacon you go to a third-party
e-commerce site and you buy something
and unless you tell it not to really
quickly it's going to go back and tell
all your friends that you just bought a
diamond engagement ring and obviously
you know that sort of secret feeling can
cause a lot of trouble there was the the
great rallying cry that facebook ruined
christmas because suddenly everyone's
purchases were being broadcast to their
entire network
zuckerberg really tried to defend it for
a while it took him a while to realize
how wrong it was
on december 5th 2007 zuckerberg made
another apology he had overreached yet
again
but as with previous mistakes it
wouldn't really matter facebook was just
too popular and it wasn't long before
zuckerberg was loosening up the
network's privacy controls one more time
more than four years after co-founding
facebook zuckerberg still seemed uneasy
in the public spotlight
what's your next thing you're gonna do
get bought
none of these rumors are true right
um you know this is making me feel very
uncomfortable
by 2009 rumors were indeed swirling that
facebook would go public instead
zuckerberg took money from a new
investor
yuri milner ceo of the russian internet
investment firm digital sky technologies
offered a 200 million dollar deal for
just 1.9 percent of the company deals of
that size are kind of never easy there's
a lot of
back and forth this deal was about the
vision that we shared how big this
company can get
everything else was sort of secondary
milner's investment allowed facebook to
continue to expand and it kept the
development of the company firmly in the
hands of its founder zuckerberg knew
that pushing facebook advertising even
further was the key to continued growth
for years zuckerberg believed that
facebook was in a unique position
today even with the most advanced
advertising systems that exist they only
have estimates of what someone's gender
might be or what someone's age might be
or what they might be interested in but
on facebook we know exactly what gender
someone is and exactly how old they are
and exactly what they're interested in
jeremy smith is chief strategy officer
for second market a company that brokers
shares and privately held companies
which cannot yet be traded on the public
market
what makes facebook so desirable from
the perspective of advertisers is that
they are able to accumulate information
on their users like nobody else the
funny thing is the users don't really
view it as data it's themselves it's
their information it's their lives that
they're putting on there but as far as
advertisers are concerned it is the the
holy grail of data
pushing the boundaries of that holy
grail of data was about to get
zuckerberg in trouble again in december
2009 he revamped the privacy settings
for facebook's then 350 million users
unless users individually restored their
settings previously private information
was now available to everyone on the
internet many people just sort of took
that default and somewhat inadvertently
allowed a lot of their information to
become public
and and many privacy advocates believe
that they didn't explain that or
disclose it sufficiently
a firestorm of complaints from users and
consumer groups forced zuckerberg to
backtrack again sparking concerns in
congress
we are here today to urge facebook's
creator and ceo
mark zuckerberg to revisit this new
policy as soon as possible we believe
facebook should reverse its policy to
begin exploring guidelines so users know
upfront what's happening
adding fuel to the fire was the
surfacing of still more instant messages
business insider published messages they
said
showed a friend asking then college aged
zuckerberg why people shared their
emails with him
zuckerberg's response was kurt and
profane you know i i mean i asked him
point blank about it and he was very
embarrassed
by them by the fact that he had sent
these ims less than one month later he
was put on the hot seat in a memorably
awkward interview at the all things
digital conference do you feel like
you're violating people's
privacy you know there were real
learning points and turning points along
the way in terms of um
in terms of
building things
if i knew what i knew now then then i
hope i wouldn't have made those mistakes
but
i can't go back and change the past i
can only do what we think is the right
thing going forward
you know anybody who's ever
kind of doubted
what facebook is about or want to
question his integrity i mean they can
they can keep pointing back to that
right to that instance of like i can't
trust that guy that is that is going to
be our check on him
for as long as he remains ceo you know
and in charge of that company it's going
to be like okay you're not that guy will
prove to us that you're not that guy
chris huffnoggle the director of privacy
programs at the university of california
berkeley believes mark zuckerberg
purposefully pushes the envelope on
privacy
in most situations where a company does
something that's unpopular they have
blow back they lose the ability to do
something but in facebook's case we have
something called i call blow forward
where
they take two steps forward there's some
type of public reaction and they just
take a little step back
and so over time they've been able to
open up profiles more and more
[Music]
mark does not think you should be a
different person at work than you are at
the bowling alley
in bed at school
you know he basically thinks you should
be consistent across all these
environments so that's a very radical
view for many older people
by the time mark zuckerberg turned 25 in
2009 he had accumulated so much
notoriety wealth and power that author
ben mesrick had written a book about him
and the founding of facebook
this story started for me at an email i
received just out of the blue to my
website and eduardo saverin was angry he
wanted to tell his story he had
co-founded facebook with mark zuckerberg
and he said had been kicked out of the
company and he felt betrayed and he
wanted to talk severan talked to mesrick
for six months about a lawsuit he filed
against his former harvard classmate for
diluting severan's share of the company
according to mesrick facebook found out
eduardo was talking to him
and they essentially settled with
eduardo nobody knows for sure what
happened but what i've heard is he got
five percent of facebook and he had to
sign an agreement that said he would
never speak to ben mesrick again but
mesrick already had enough material for
his book my proposal had leaked out on
the web aaron sorkin saw it
scott rudin saw it
so sorkin immediately signed on to write
the screenplay and everything happened
very quickly from there the pre-release
publicity surrounding the movie also
seemed to force zuckerberg to go on a pr
offensive
the previously pressed shy zuckerberg
was suddenly everywhere if you build
something great that's what people care
about when people don't care about what
someone says about you in a movie he
gave oprah a tour of his house in 2010
and announced on her show a 100 million
dollar donation to public schools in
newark new jersey 100 million
[Applause]
the social network opened in wide
release on october 1st 2010.
people want to go on the internet and
check out their friends so why not build
a website that offers that friends
pictures profiles i'm talking about
taking the entire social experience of
college and putting it online
zuckerberg complained about his
on-screen portrait as a ruthless
socially challenged power geek with no
friends he said there were factual
errors in the script
frame it as if the whole reason for
making facebook and building something
was because i
wanted to get girls or wanted to get
into some kind of social institution um
and i mean the reality for people who
know me is i've actually been dating the
same girl since before i started
facebook they just can't wrap their head
around the idea that someone might build
something because they like building
things
[Applause]
though he initially said he wouldn't see
the movie zuckerberg ended up taking his
entire staff to it he even showed up on
saturday night live you ever end up uh
seeing seeing the film that
the social network yeah i i did cool
thanks uh and uh what did you uh what'd
you think it was interesting
thank you to the hollywood farm press
for this extraordinary honor the social
network won a golden globe award for
best dramatic picture as well as three
academy awards
first tunisia now egypt what's next
but to an increasing number of people
around the world
facebook wasn't just a hollywood movie
it was affecting real life
in late 2010 demonstrators started
taking to the streets in tunisia and
later in egypt to protest their
repressive governments by this time more
than 70 percent of facebook's half a
billion plus users lived outside the
united states in egypt one flash point
for the anger was a case of police
brutality at the center of the protests
was a google employee who ran a facebook
page
walgonnam was the manager in egypt of a
page that was a memorial to this guy who
had been beaten tortured and killed by
the secret police
[Music]
and that group became very very large
many many hundreds of thousands of
members
during the period leading up to the
revolt against mubarak
[Music]
facebook expedited the ability of people
to express their dissatisfaction which
clearly
sped up the process of these revolts
the governments of tunisia and egypt
fell
protesters expressed their gratitude to
facebook on the streets
one named his newborn daughter facebook
and while gonim sang the social
networking sites praises on cnn i want
to meet mark zuckerberg one day and
thank him i'm talking on behalf of egypt
this revolution started on facebook when
hundreds of thousands of egyptians
started collaborating content you know
like we would post a video on on
facebook they would be shared by 50 000
people on their walls
within few hours
facebook itself was was very quick to
try to distance themselves from that
political activity i mean obviously they
supported it but they don't really want
to be seen as a tool of change because
obviously facebook wants to be active in
regimes like china they don't
necessarily
want themselves viewed as a tool of
insurgency
zuckerberg has taken on a personal goal
that might help him with his mission to
connect the world
he says he spends an hour a day studying
chinese which could potentially help him
gain a billion new friends
it's the fastest growing and the biggest
internet market in the world there are
hundreds of millions of users and his
mission is incomplete if he's not in
china mark zuckerberg's power had never
been greater and once again speculation
grew that he would take his company
public despite enormous pressure
zuckerberg has been hesitant to pull the
trigger and cash in 100 years 200 years
from now what's going to be more
important the money
right
or the fact that he has had this kind of
impact or the fact that he's you know
executed and developed and helped evolve
this thing that is more than just a
technology site and it's more than just
a website
and so i think that's why it's never
been about money and it's never been
about status when companies go public
it's a tremendous strain on the
management and in fact on top of all of
that
when you go public you you open yourself
up to even greater government scrutiny
aware of that scrutiny facebook has
amped up their presence in washington
with a team that includes several former
white house aides and influential
capitol hill insiders political official
after political official will tell you
if you are absent from the debate
um you're likely to be the person who
kind of gets cut out and so presence in
that debate particularly when you know
google and yahoo and microsoft and a
number of other very large players are
spending a lot on lobbying is a mistake
today
several facebook founders including
mark's friends and classmates have left
the company to start new ventures on
their own they've been dubbed the
facebook mafia
but much of silicon valley talent is on
their way in top programmers are leaving
companies like google to be a part of
zuckerberg's momentum and facebook and
google the two internet behemoths are
competing in other ways ryan single is a
staff writer for wired magazine facebook
and google's relationship is pretty
simple they really they just don't like
each other they're really i mean they're
competing cultures um
you know facebook was sort of young
brash
wild and google is like you know an
algorithm company like these are guys
that like any problem there's got to be
a way that they can write a little
algorithm that'll fix it
it's clear that google missed the rise
of social and eric schmidt has has
admitted to to being flat-footed
around facebook and around social
they've tried a number of things most
spectacularly the buzz social network
that just hasn't worked then in may of
2011
facebook was embarrassed when it was
revealed that they had launched a secret
attack on google
facebook is doing damage control after
revelations it hired a pr firm to plant
negative stories about google facebook
claimed publicly it was not a smear
campaign but the exchange revealed just
how vicious the competition has become
the whole burst in marcello flap was was
really just an in-your-face expression
of the animosity that has sprung up not
only between these two companies but
almost the personal shakespearean drama
that's playing out between google and
between facebook which frankly has a lot
of former google execs who would like
nothing more than to supplant their
former company you can't underestimate
how driven mark zuckerberg really is he
says his mission is to you know make the
world more open a better place his
mission is also to be
number one right he wants to be
you know inscribed on granite above bill
gates i think he is well on his way like
gates another harvard dropout
zuckerberg is a fierce competitor he
moved quickly to vanquish rivals google
and twitter with a stunning acquisition
in april 2012
instagram is off the market in an
instant facebook likes the photo sharing
app so much it's paying 1 billion
dollars for it in cash and shares ahead
of its ipo but the app is free and has
little known revenue still facebook may
need instagram more than instagram needs
the money instagram has become a photo
sharing competitor and a social network
all its own it was considered a radical
and defensive move facebook cannot take
any chance that any other social network
oriented toward photos could really get
traction that would come you know com
compare to theirs and i think so there's
a preemptive quality to this also i
think almost certainly google was
interested and probably maybe forced
facebook to act now
one month later facebook finally went
public in the largest ipo on record for
an internet company making mark
zuckerberg a multi-billionaire this is
an awesome moment the ceo and hoodie and
sneakers retain tight control of his
company with 57 of shareholder voting
rights facebook has literally changed
the world we've moved
from the country to the village to the
town to facebook it's just getting
started too i think it's just going to
get bigger and bigger and bigger
for a site that's able to move from the
dorm room to a site where you know my 80
year old mother and myself and my
chiropractor and my third grade class
all reunites on the site and we all have
something to talk about
it's an achievement
zuckerberg is just
as visionary as steve jobs
he's going to prove just as influential
as bill gates
but he's not dealing with a piece of
gadget he's not dealing with some
program he's dealing with our lives he's
dealing with our identities so that's
why i think we're all going to have to
kind of keep him in check in a way
we make decisions at facebook not
optimizing for you know what
is going to happen in the next year but
what's going to set us up to really be
in this world where every product
experience that you have is social and
that's all powered by facebook